الحديث اكثر عن انطلاق مهرجان البحر
الاحمر السينمائي اليوم ينضم الينا من جده
انطوان خليفه مدير برنامج العربي بمهرجان
اهلا بكم معنا سيد انطوان حديثنا اكثر عن
الاستعدادات لدوره المهرجان هذا العام
صباح الخير لكم وانا سعيد بوجودكم
واستعدادات قائمه ونحن جدا جدا ساعدين اذا
ممكن
كثير كثير مستعدين
وحابين النشاط والحيويه اللي عم بتصير
بالمملكه وتحضيرات
اكثر الصوره لنسخه الثانيه من مهرجان
البحر الاحمر بماذا تختلف وما الجديد فيها
عن اي افلام مشاركه نتحدث ونوعيه هذه
الافلام
حابين انه هذا المهرجين يكون المهرجان
الشعبي مهرجين لجمهور يعني لازم ناس
يعرفوا انه فيهن يجوا يحضروا الافلام في
اسعار مخفضه
المهرجان الخيسير بمنطقه
انما ايضا بالريد سيمو حيث عندنا صالات
فوكس من صالات مخصصه للعروض في عروض
عالميه في عروض عربيه في افلام سعوديه
كل الدول العربيه تقريبا مشاركه سنه ان
الكويت او تونس او لبنان او العراق او
فلسطين او سوريا او المغرب
همم الاشتراك الافلام العربيه من الدول
العربيه موجوده من فلسطين وايضا احنا
عندنا افلام جدا عالميه من العالم بعد ما
اشوفه هو كانت عرضت بمهرجانات عالميه عم
نرجع نعرضها وافلام عطارد للمره الاولى
عالميه طيب ستطوان سيتم تكريم همم نجوم
عالميين وحضور مخرجين عالمين ايضا حدثنا
عن ابرز المواهب وابرز النجوم المشاهير
الذين سيحضرون المهرجان هذا العام
جدا جدا بتكريم يسرى
وبعدين عم نكرر الفنان الكبير شاروخان
مخرج من بريطانيا
همم
موجوده
كثير مطروح اليوم شو السبب خلي بالك من
زوزو
ما احلى سؤالك نحنا عم يعني نقول له
الفيلم انتر سنه 72 ونحنا بال22 الى 50
سنه ومؤسسه البحر الاحمر مهرجان البحر
الاحمر
بالطريقه جدا جدا جديده وسعيدين وساعديني
انه يكون معنا استاذ حسين فهميته
له 50 سنه
بصراحه هل يمكن يوما ما ان يصل مستوى
مهرجان البحر الاحمر لمستوى مهرجانات
نحن نعمل شاهدا انه الفيلم يكون انه
المهرجان يكون محترف انه المهرجان يكون
عندنا شغفي انه العالم جمهور السعودي
جمهور العربي يجوا يستمتعوا يشوفوا افلام
بيغيروا نظرهم الاشياء بالشغل ممكن نوصال
طبعا هذا الشيء الاساسي بالنسبه لنا وهيدا
جوهر شغلنا احنا نتمنى ذلك شكرا جزيلا
انطوان خليفه مدير البرنامج العربي